la très contestée visite d'État du
colonel Kaddafi en France a débuté cet
après-midi une grande limousine blanche
un cortège composé d'une centaine de
véhicules officiels enveloppé d'une toge
et prenant le temps de passer en revue
un détachement de la garde nationale le
chef d'État libien savourait
manifestement à l'instant sa visite
durera 5 jours elle dérange jusque dans
les rangs du gouvernement Nora
bouedra sur le tarmac de l'aéroport
d'orli ministre de l'Intérieur Michel
alomarie et sa délégation ont dû
patienter une fois de plus le Guide de
la révolution libyenne s'est fait
attendre il est 15h et le moment est
historique le colonel Kaddafi n'était
pas revenu depuis 34
ans tapis rouge pour celui qui il y a
peu encore étéit considéré comme un
paria aujourd'hui c'est en chef d'État
respecter qu'il est accueilli par la
France puis à bord de sa limousine le
bien prend la direction de
l'Élysée autour du palais malgré la
pluie froide il flotte comme un parfum
d'Orient autre moment fort de la journée
dans la cour de l'Élysée les honneurs de
la
République qui sait ce qui peut bien se
passer dans la tête de ce Bédoin grand
admirateur de la Révolution française
dont il connaî dit-on chaque épisode sur
le bout des
doigts quelle reconnaissance surtout ce
moment il en a tant
rêvé premières discussions et premiers
entretiens puis Nicolas Sarkozi a
provise une conférence de presse pour
mettre les choses au
clair j'ai dit au président
Kaddafi combien il fallait continuer à
progresser sur le chemin des droits de
l'homme dans tous ces aspects tout ce
qu'il restait à faire mais à
l'inverse que dirions-nous aujourd'hui
au dirigeants
iraniens si nous ne tendions pas la main
au dirigeant libien qui a choisi
lui-même de tourner le dos à l'arme
nucléaire et au
terrorisme pendant ce temps dehors les
manifestants ont été tenus à l'écart C
après-midi la police a interpellé 54
personnes place de la Concorde des
opposants au colonel kadfi qui souitaent
organiser un
CTIN rien ne doit perturber cette
journée riche en promesse de
contratance devrait signer pour plus de
10 milliards d'euros de contrat
désarmement un réacteur nucléaire pour
der l'E de mer et peut-être aussi des
avions
rafales